Right into audience questions for the week.
First one is, Hey David, I get Michael Bloomberg
is doing okay in the polls, but what's the
point of him campaigning for the presidency?
He can't win.
He's [inaudible],
he's nearly 80 years old.
He's merely hemorrhaging cash.
What is the point of this entire thing?
So I think there's a couple of different things
going on.
Number one, the spending of the money, so
given that Michael Bloomberg is running for
him, the spending of the money, he probably
sees as a better and more efficient way to
get his message directly to voters than participation
in the debates after having an individual
donation infrastructure.
So he's chosen to forego individual donations.
He spending a whole bunch of money, it could
be 150 million by now, could could be even
more.
I don't know that we have the latest tally
and he believes that he has a good message
and he is choosing to go directly to voters
and that explains the spending of the money.
If you have 55 billion spending 100 million
or 200 million or 300 million, these are unconscionable
amounts of money for 99.99% of the population
or or more.
But to Michael Bloomberg, it's really, it's
barely anything, particularly when he's nearly
80 years old and he has all the money and
his kids, I don't know anything about his
family, but his kids, I'm sure I have all
the money they could ever need, so the spending
of the money, you have to think about it as
like spending pennies and that's effectively
what he is doing.
Secondly, I think the strategy of running
at all, because again, if the thing doesn't
change drastically, he is obviously not going
to be the nominee.
There is a gamble that Biden fails and people
get scared of voting Bernie or voting Warren
and Bloomberg is there with name recognition
and having built up a campaign infrastructure
as well as just blasting out hundreds of millions
of dollars in ads.
Now it may not work because the the obvious
alternative to an establishment Democrat like
Biden is not to go to the guy who got in late,
hasn't been in any of the debates and was
a Republican for a long time in his life.
I think they go to boot edge edge or they
go to Amy Klobuchar to fill the establishment
role if were to totally falter.
I do believe that underlying all of this,
I believe Michael Bloomberg is sincere, that
he wants to remove Donald Trump at all costs
and there was the concern of, well Bloomberg's
in there because he's super rich and he wants
to protect his own wealth.
There's probably ways in which that's true,
but he may also be wanting to protect merely
the structures that allow him to make money
rather than avoiding a wealth tax.
Personally, because I read over the weekend
that he said he would support whoever the
democratic nominee ultimately is, including
Elizabeth Warren, whose wealth tax would directly
affect Michael Bloomberg, and I'm sure he
doesn't believe that her wealth tax will become
a reality and that's probably a good assessment.
He says he would vote for Bernie, so on and
so forth.
So I don't want another billionaire president.
I've not seen evidence that Michael Bloomberg
is acting in bad faith.
And of course it's F w what his candidacy
really is, is not evidence of a guy acting
in bad faith.
It's just evidence of why the money and politics
system that we have is so corrosive because
he switched from being a Republican to a Democrat
during Donald Trump's tenure, bought his way
in without being in a single debate and his
polling at last check, something like five
or 6%.
I don't think he's a bad faith actor, but
he does show us why the system we have doesn't
work and why it should be very quickly changed.
I a also, by the way, I would love to get
a phone call when we do live calls from a
Michael Bloomberg supporter.
I jokingly tweeted over the weekend that I,
I, I met a real Amy Klobuchar supporter in
real life and I, I in, in person, I don't
think I know anyone who's supporting Clover
char or Biden.
I know a couple people I'm friends with on
Facebook who are supporting mayor Pete.
Um, I don't, I've not talked to anyone who
is supporting Michael Bloomberg and I would
love to get a call from them during live calls
next week.
So if you're supporting Bloomberg, I want
to hear from you.
Is it issue oriented?
Is it personality, is it you want a billionaire
to face off against Trump or what exactly
is it that you see as appealing about Michael
Bloomberg?